The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So let's get started.
[CHATTER]
Oh, it's interesting that
some of your questions
had to do with things that I
didn't quite cover in lecture,
but that's fine.
I'm going to cover them at the
beginning of today's lecture.
This is a really
important question.
How do you know
what channel is at--
how do you know what ion
a particular channel is
conducting?
It's actually hard to determine.
There are various ways to do
it, where you can specifically
label the ion, or
follow a particular ion,
and address whether or not
it's getting into a cell
or across a membrane, when
there's a particular ion
channel present.
But it's not completely trivial.
One of the things I didn't have
time to go through with you,
but which is one of
the PowerPoints though,
is the fact that ion channels
are really selective.
And they don't conduct ions
on the basis of size, OK?
So you're not going to get
a large ion channel that
could accommodate a large ion,
also accommodating a small ion.
It's not a matter about of
just opening up a space.
There are also
charge considerations
where the ions actually
interact with the molecules
in the channel, in the actual
pore through the membrane.
And it's that interaction which
selects for a particular ion.
But this notion of exactly what
ions channels are conducting
has been many, many
decades of work.
And what I've written
up here is correct.
But if you want to
explore it more with me,
come and talk
during office hours.
And then a number of
you started asking me
about modulation of
neurotransmitters, which I'll
talk about in today's lecture.
And these are
clearly of interest,
because many recreational
drugs and medications modulate
neurotransmitter amounts.
And that is how they work.
So for example,
some of you might
be taking things called SSRIs,
specific serotonin re-uptake
inhibitors like
Prozac, which make
you feel less anxious
and better about things.
And these act by prolonging
serotonin activity,
by preventing it from being
retaken up into cells.
And I'll touch on this at
the beginning of the lecture.
And it takes a while--
is what I've written here--
for these medications to start
working, because you're really
asking for a rearrangement
of the whole synaptic process
and the synaptic structure,
in order that they can work.
And here is another one.
What about amphetamines?
Are they neurotransmitters?
No.
They increase the
release of dopamine,
which is a neurotransmitter,
and they also
seem to inhibit re-uptake of
dopamine and serotonin is all.
I'll talk about re-uptake
very briefly in a moment.
For many medications, both--
actually, for many medications,
no matter whether or not
they affect your brain or
other parts of your body,
the precise mechanism of
action is really not known.
There are guesses.
There's data.
But the precise mechanism
is often not known.
So let's use that as a
segue into our lecture.
I won't have office hours
today, due to my schedule.
I will have them next Wednesday
due to the vacation schedule.
And you're welcome to
email me in the meantime.
All right.
We've been walking
through the cells involved
in nervous system
formation-- the connections
between the cells.
And now today we're
going to finish
talking about the
connections between the cells
and segue into the incredibly
complex topic of circuits
in the nervous system.
So today, the first thing
I want to talk about
is regulating synapses.
And you remember
that we're talking
about chemical synapses.
And the second thing I want
to talk about are circuits.
Is there a problem?
Can you hear me OK at the back?
Thumbs up.
Great.
Good.
When I introduced circuits--
when I introduced synapses
to you, I told you that one
of the reasons that there
was this chemical synapse in
the midst with a slow chemicals
synapse, in the midst of this
rapid electrical transmission,
was because you could
regulate synapses.
And that is really
what fine tunes us.
It allows us to respond
in a graded way to stimuli
both from within the
body and outside.
It allows the body to adapt in
ways that are not all or none,
where action potentials
are all or none.
The overall response of
the body clearly isn't.
It's very nuanced.
And all of this has to do with
regulating chemical synapses.
And that's what we'll talk
about for a few moments.
You can regulate
chemical synapses
by changing the amount
of neurotransmitter.
And if you think about
this for a moment,
if you think about
the synapse, there's
the neurotransmitter released
into the space between the two
cells, diffuses across
the synaptic cleft,
and then does something to the
post synaptic cell, potentially
to lead to an action potential.
Now if that neurotransmitter
stuck around
in the space between
the cells, it
would keep stimulating
the postsynaptic cell
over and over.
And as more neurotransmitter
was released,
so the postsynaptic cell
would be further stimulated.
And you would get to a point
where the post synaptic neuron
was completely over stimulated.
And that's clearly not a way
to regulate responsiveness
to any stimuli.
So neurotransmitter does not
stay in the synaptic cleft
for very long.
So it's changing the
amount of neurotransmitter
via degradation.
Once neurotransmitter is
released, in some cases,
it's degraded by
specific enzymes.
For example, in the
case of acetylcholine,
there's a particular enzyme
that breaks down acetylcholine.
And if that enzyme is inhibited,
you go into respiratory shock.
You cannot breathe anymore,
because you have to activate
and inactivate the muscles via
the nerves, as you breathe.
You can also regulate the
amount of neurotransmitter
by something called re-uptake,
sometimes called reabsorption,
where the neurotransmitter--
absorb-- tion-- where the
neurotransmitter is released.
And then it's taken up by the
presynaptic cell, which is
a frugal way of doing things.
It doesn't have to
keep synthesizing
the neurotransmitter, and that--
so reabsorb-- re-uptake
by the presynaptic cell.
And that is the case for
serotonin and dopamine.
And then in some
cases, you can regulate
the synthesis, the amount
of neurotransmitter
that's being made.
And the big class of
neurotransmitters regulated
in this way are the
endorphins, which
are a group of peptide
neurotransmitters
that are the natural opiates
of the body, the natural pain
regulators of the body.
And all of these
processes are regulatable
both for modulating
normal synapses,
and also in all cases,
for medication targets,
for drug targets--
so normal modulation
and drug targets.
Let's look at a
couple of slides.
Acetylcholine is
a neurotransmitter
that binds its receptor on
the postsynaptic membrane.
And after it's done so,
acetylcholinesterase,
the E here, comes and breaks it
down and stops it restimulating
the postsynaptic cell.
Many nerve gases-- sarin was
one of the famous ones that was
used in the Japanese
underground some years ago--
inhibit acetylcholinesterase.
And in that case,
you get a buildup
of acetylcholine in the post--
in the synaptic cleft.
You get repeated stimulation
of the postsynaptic cell.
And that leads to, as
I said, respiratory
paralysis and death.
Our troops overseas have
with them vials of atropine.
Atropine is a competitive
inhibitor of acetylcholine--
binds to the receptor and
prevents acetylcholine
from binding.
And in the case of
a nerve gas attack,
if you inject yourself
with atropine,
you'll stop the
acetylcholine from working.
And you'll be OK.
You get a little kind
of floppy, but you
can survive, because
they're ultimate mechanisms
of stimulating those nerves.
OK.
Here's serotonin, the
re-uptake pathway.
Serotonin is released as
all neurotransmitters,
and then it's reabsorbed
by the presynaptic cell.
And SSRIs, whose
mechanism of action
is really not
understood, do something
to block the re-uptake
of serotonin.
All right.
The other way, clearly,
that one could modulate
how often synapses are
active, or how often
the postsynaptic
cell is stimulated,
is by modulating the receptors.
Intuitively, if you
have more receptors,
the neurotransmitter
has more places to bind.
It can send a greater signal
by changing membrane potential,
if you decrease the number
of receptors, and so on.
And it turns out, if you
modify the receptors,
if you put phosphate
groups on them,
sometimes you can also
change how well they act.
So the other thing to do to
modulate synaptic activity
is by changing the receptors.
And there are really
three ways to do this--
change in number or
change in the type--
the subtype of receptor--
where there might be
a subtle change in amino acid.
Because you are using
now a different gene
to make the receptor.
You can increase or change the
affinity for neurotransmitter.
And you can change
receptor responsiveness.
All of these three
things have got something
to do with learning and memory.
They have to do with addiction.
And all of these
changes are slow.
They occur over minutes,
days, weeks, even.
And for some, we understand
how these changes occur,
but for many, we don't.
The outcome of changing
the receptors--
and I see we have
a board issue here.
So I'm going to put this on--
actually, let me put
this board down--
and this board up.
One of the outcomes
of changing all
of these parameters
about the receptors
is that over a long
period of time,
you really change
how a synapse works.
And you can change how a synapse
works through these parameters,
by repeatedly stimulating
that synapse, OK?
This is what practice does.
When you practice your
musical instrument,
or you practice your
biochemistry problems,
and you do it over
and over, you're
changing the synapses that allow
you to engage these problems.
And these processes
have got names.
So let me just complete this.
So by changing receptors so that
repeated synaptic stimulation--
changes the responsiveness
of the synapse--
generally, as I say, through
the receptors in this case.
OK.
And there are two outputs.
One, you can increase
the synaptic response.
You can make it more
likely that there'll
be an action potential.
And that would take place
at excitatory synapses.
And this process is known
as a long term potentiation.
It's the stuff you
want when you're
trying to learn something.
It's believed to be
the way memory works.
You can also
decrease the response
of a particular
synapse, and that
would work if it was
an inhibitory synapse.
And in that case, the
process is called long term--
let's just write it out--
long term depression.
Both of these processes have
been shown to work in the lab,
in culture--
hard to do those
experiments on real animals.
But it's believed that
that's how memory works.
So in your first handout, I've
drawn out for you the idea.
Here is a normal axon.
The presynaptic and
the postsynaptic cell--
neurotransmitters released.
It engages receptors.
And at some frequency, there's
an action potential elicited.
If you change-- if you
repeatedly stimulate that axon
over time--
days, minutes-- you change
the receptor spectrum
on the postsynaptic cell.
And in long term, potentiation
responsiveness increases.
Whereas in long
term depression, you
decrease receptor number,
or some other parameter,
and you lead to
decreased responsiveness.
OK.
Let us move on to our
second topic, which
is that of circuits,
which refers
to multiple connectivities--
multiple synapses forming
in a way that is stable,
and that can lead to particular
outcomes of particular stimuli.
Let's look at your
next handout to try
to get a sense of where we are.
So I've diagrammed
this out for you.
And I've started
here with some kind
of sensory neuron, an
interneuron, and a motor
neuron--
three connected neurons.
You could put a lot of
these other things called
interneurons in the way.
Sensory neurons receive signals.
Motor neurons tell things to
happen, like muscles to work.
And interneurons, of
which there can be many,
are the connectors between
sensory and motor neurons.
There's an input, and
there's an output.
And what happens in between--
this is a synthesis
of what we've
talked about over the
last couple of lectures.
The sensory neuron
makes multiple synapses
onto the interneuron.
They can be excitatory
or inhibitory.
They're summated.
The interneuron then
decides whether to make
an action potential or not--
action potential-- yes
or no in each case.
If it makes an
action potential, it
sends its signal to the next
neuron, the motor neuron.
That motor neuron is
getting a bunch of inputs--
excitatory and inhibitory.
And it, again, has to decide
whether or not there's
an action potential, OK?
So that's the context
that puts circuits,
where we have been discussing
the process of setting up
the connections in
the nervous system.
The thing about circuits-- and
here's a term you should know--
is that they have to do
with axon pathfinding.
And so let's, for a moment,
forget this diagram, which
is a diagram of what
there is in the adult.
And let's think about how
these circuits are set up.
The circuits that we have in
our brains and then our bodies
are of the close to uncountable.
I'm not sure we ever will count
them in an animal as complex
as ourselves.
It's been done in
caenorhabditis,
which has got 1,000
cells-- the little
worm we talked about--
it's got 1,000 cells.
And all of the connections
in caenorhabditis
have been mapped.
And they are extremely complex.
But that's just a
handful of neurons.
When you're talking
about 10 to the 10th, 10
to the 11th neurons, those
connections are enormous.
But we can ask some
basic questions, OK?
And let's just state it.
Neurons are connected
to form circuits.
We can say that they're
functional circuits,
if you like.
That is implicit.
And the big question is,
how do these circuits
know where to form?
Or if you like the
restatement, how
do the neurons
know where to go--
know to go and where to connect?
And there are two kind
of intuitive answers,
both of which turn
out to be correct.
Either the neurons just
go every which way.
And if it works,
that's retained,
and the rest of the connections
just are dissolved and go away.
And that's true.
But the bigger truth is that the
neurons are told where to go.
So you can phrase these
that the neurons undergo
some kind of random process
where neurons survive
if connections are made.
Or there's some kind
of guided process
where the neurons
are told where to go.
And both of these turn out,
after many, many years of work,
to be correct.
Let's look at some slides here.
This is work from Professor
Fee, over in Brain and Cognitive
Science.
He studies these little
birds and their song circuit,
which forms and reforms
during the life of the bird.
The circuit is complicated.
These are not single neurons.
They are bundles of neurons.
But it's kind of mappable.
And this is one of the circuits.
It's got something to do with
song within the bird brain.
It's not the entire circuit.
That's one of the things
that's going on here on campus.
But when you start thinking
about things like language--
I really like this slide.
Because these are activity
plots of the brain that
can be done in a number of ways
by monitoring oxygen uptake,
or glucose use.
But you can look and
see different parts
of the brain are active.
And when you think
about language--
here are these four
parts of the brain.
Actually, here is a
huge part of the brain
used to generate words.
Each of these parts of the
brain are millions and millions
of neurons, which are
connected to one another
within these regions.
And then each of these regions
is connected to one another.
And each of those
regions is connected
to the output, which would be
all of your vocal apparatus.
And all of this is connected
to your auditory apparatus,
to your visual system, so
that you can read words.
They can be
processed, and so on.
The connections
that give language
probably take a very
large part of your brain.
I would throw out 15%
to 20% of your brain
is involved in some
aspect of language--
receiving,
generating, or output.
And the circuits there,
as I said, are enormous.
OK.
So do neurons know where to go?
Let me go with you.
This isn't on your handout.
This is to look on the screen.
Do neurons know
where to connect?
There was a very famous
experiment done by Sperry,
some many years ago--
Roger Sperry-- who got a
Nobel Prize for his work--
that involved a frog.
And it involved figuring out
where the neurons in the retina
went.
So it turns out, if
you look at your eyes,
OK, there are neurons
that go from your eye
back into your brain.
The neurons on the
side of your nose
are called the nasal neurons.
And the neurons on
the side of you,
or the outside of your face,
are called temporal neurons.
And what Sperry did was
to take an adult frog
and rotate the
eye 180 degrees so
that the nasal neurons would now
be on the outside of the head.
The temporal neurons would be
on the inside of the head, OK?
And for a while
after the operation,
the frog was really confused.
But after a while, it
actually recovered.
Now let's lay out this--
and the recovery, as
I'm going to tell you,
told Sperry and the world that
neurons were told where to go.
So here is the retina
depicted as a circle.
And here's a part of the
brain called the optic tectum,
that the neurons connect to.
It's the first part
of their circuit.
Here are the temporal
neurons connecting
to the C region of the
brain, and the nasal
neurons connecting
to the R region.
So after this rotation,
there were two possibilities.
One was that the
axons growing out.
So let's just be clear.
In this rotation, these
axons were severed.
They were cut.
They had to regrow and find
their targets, if they could.
So one possibility would be
that the axons would grow out
of this retina, and
they'd grow everywhere.
And they wouldn't make
really wrong connections.
And things would be a mess.
In actual fact,
what really happened
was that the nasal
neurons, even though they
were on the wrong
side of the face,
found their way to the R region.
And the tactile neurons found
their way to the C region,
just like they had
connected to before.
And this was a really
profound experiment
that told investigators
that axons knew where to go.
And we know the molecular
basis of this now,
but I'm not going to
tell you about it.
In order to understand more
about this guidance process,
you need to understand
a part of the axon
that we haven't discussed,
and a time in the neurons life
that we haven't
discussed either.
And that is a time when
neurons are growing.
Most neuronal growth takes place
during embryonic development,
but it continues
throughout life.
And so this is a developmental
process, but also
in that experiment,
that was an adult frog.
OK.
So guidance of neurons--
and as we'll discuss,
particularly axons--
occurs during
development and repair--
and learning as well.
We can put that up as well--
during development, repair,
and learning.
Although I'd say
for learning there's
a bit of a question mark
whether that's true.
But I think it's probably true.
OK.
And the cell that
we need to consider
is a committed neuron, which
is called a neuroblast.
It doesn't matter.
But here's your
committed neuron.
You have to think back
to past lectures--
a neuron that knows that
it's going to be a neuron
but hasn't decided to--
hasn't become one yet--
hasn't differentiated.
It's called a neuroblast.
And here it is.
It's just a cell body
with the nucleus.
And over time, this
neuroblast sends out
processes that are
called neurites.
They initially look the same.
Soon some of them
become dendrites.
And one of them
becomes an axon--
some neurite, axon,
plus dendrite outgrowth.
So you have a cell now
with some processes.
And one of these is
going to be the axon.
And that axon grows.
And it's during
that growth process
that it figures out where to go.
The cell body doesn't move.
The dendrites don't move.
It's the axon that is
doing the pathfinding.
So the axon extends and
eventually finds its target.
And this extension is a growth
process that we'll talk about.
OK.
For every-- a nerve--
when we talk about nerves--
there are actually many--
many neurons, many axons.
There are bundles of axons.
And there is something
about the first axon
to find a target,
that's very important--
the pioneer axon.
The first one finds the target.
And then others follow--
the same path that
lays down a path.
And they form bundles,
also called fascicles.
And these fascicles
together make the nerve.
The part of the
axon that's really
important for this process
is the very tip of the axon,
and it has a special name
called the growth cone.
So the axon tip, or the
growth cone, is crucial.
And we can draw it on the board.
If we now draw an axon--
and we've blown it up now.
So usually we blow
up and we lose bits,
but now we're not going
to lose any bit of it.
Here's the axon.
And down the length of the axon
are parallel microtubules--
many of them.
And these microtubules
both stabilize the axon
and also transport substances
to and from the cell body.
So they stabilize the
shape of very long axons,
and they also transport,
like little railway tracks,
substances to and
from the cell body.
That's not the tip of the axon.
At the very tip, the
microtubules end,
and they interdigitate with
these finger-like protrusions,
which are very dynamic.
That means they
change all the time.
And these protrusions protrude
because of polymerized actin.
And you might be saying, we
heard about that already.
Yes.
You've heard about
that in morphogenesis.
We've talked about this.
Cell biology is cell biology,
whether it's about neurons,
or cells in your stomach,
or cells in your--
that give rise to the
hairs on your head.
All of these cells
are just cells.
So there are these
protrusions at the end.
So this whole thing is the axon.
But the very end
is the growth cone.
This very end is
the growth cone.
And these protrusions go
by the name of filopodia,
filamentous, and lamellipodia,
more flattened feet.
And they protrude because of
the polymerization of actin
within them.
So there's F-actin
leads to protrusions.
Well, that's one
important thing.
And I'll show you
a movie in a moment
to show you that
as an axon grows,
it's sending out zillions
of these things all the time
that are feeling their
way around the place.
Actually, I'll-- no.
I won't show you now, because
there's an intervening slide.
But the other thing you should
know is that like all cells,
there are receptors on the
surface of the growth cone
that are also sampling what
ligands are in the environment.
And if the ligands
are favorable,
they will either stabilize
these protrusions
and make more of
them to take place.
So here are receptors
all over the place.
This is a receptor.
And if receptors
contact ligands,
then again, you will
get F-actin formed.
And protrusions will be formed.
And they will be stabilized.
OK.
The growth cone is
paramount to axon outgrowth.
There are signals which both
attract axons towards them,
and signals which repel axons.
We can call those,
not surprisingly,
attractive signals.
We'll talk about
some in a moment.
And in that case, the
growth cone extends.
And it extends-- not
to beat a dead horse
here-- but because F-actin
increases or is stabilized.
And the flip is
that the growth cone
can be destabilized
and literally collapse
under repulsive signals.
The growth cone collapses.
And it collapses because
F-actin now becomes
G globula, or
unpolymerized actin,
using exactly the same
processes that we talked about
during the
morphogenesis lecture.
Let's look at a
couple of slides.
You don't have these.
So just look on the screen.
This is a cell drawn in
Professor Lodish's book.
Here's the leading
edge of the cell.
The direction of the
cell is where there
is lots of polymerized actin.
This I've just
drawn on the board.
And here is an
axonal growth code.
And I really like this movie.
It's a time lapse
taken over 10 minutes.
And you can see all these things
at the end and on the sides--
these protrusions from
the cell-- very active.
They're forming.
They're disaggregating, forming
again and disaggregating
as the cell-- those
of the lamellipodia
and the filopodia--
as the cell is feeling its
way through the environment--
trying to find
somewhere to go, OK?
So this is a real exploratory
process by the cell.
Good.
What are these guidance signals?
Well, this is not
a mystery either.
Ligands-- we know
about receptors.
You know about the guidance
signals are ligands.
And these ligands, when
they're bound to a receptor,
lead to signal transduction
and axon outgrowth.
So ligands-- and we'll put in
parentheses, plus receptors--
to signal transduction-- and
a change in the growth cone.
There are two kinds
of guidance signals
that are reasonably
separate from one another.
They're called short range and
long range guidance signals.
Short range signals
require contact
between the axon and the
extracellular matrix,
or the axon and another cell.
So there's some localized
accumulation of a signal,
and that has to be directly
contacted by the growth cone--
so require axon ECM,
or cell contact.
These signals are
not diffusible.
Therefore-- and
they include things
like laminin, which is a part
of the extracellular matrix,
but also an axon
guidance signal.
And then there are
long range signals,
which would be the flip
of the short range.
These are diffusible.
And they can be concentration
dependent in their effect.
And we talked about
things like this
previously when we
talked about morphogens--
other ligands that can act
at different concentrations
in different ways.
OK.
And an example that I'll
explore more with you
is the netrin protein.
All right.
Let me see what I have here.
OK, this is nice.
This is on your-- this
is your next handout.
And this is an assay for
short range guidance signals.
It's called a stripe assay.
And this was how it was found.
What those nasal and temporal
retinal neurons grew on--
the idea is you
take a plastic dish,
and you put stripes of
different molecules on the dish.
And then you put neurons all the
way along one side of the dish.
And you look at them.
You ask where they grow.
And they'll choose
where to grow.
And if they like one
of the molecules,
if they can interact with one
of the molecules on the dish,
they will grow in
particular stripes,
and not in other stripes.
And that gives you your
experiment and control
in one dish.
This is what it looks like.
So here are the neurons from
the nasal side of the retina.
And those nasal
neurons, which project
to the R side of the tectum,
grow on our membranes,
but not on C membranes,
which is where they don't go.
You may not have this, but you
can go back and look at this
later on.
All right.
But let's move on
now to an example
that I want to spend
a bit of time on.
And the example of a long
range signal is that the netrin
in the spinal cord.
And what we're
going to talk about
are two types of
neurons, one of which
are growing down the spinal
cord from the back, more
towards the belly, and
another type of neuron that's
growing more from the belly
side of the spinal cord, back
towards the back, OK?
And those neurons
always know where to go.
And it turns out they are told
where to go by the same signal.
So there are two
types of neurons.
There are these things
called commissural neurons.
And they grow
ventrally, or down,
towards something
called the floor plate.
I'll show you in the diagram.
And then there are
these other ones
called trochlear neurons
that grow dorsally, or up.
And they grow away from this
thing called the floor plate.
And it turns out,
using an explant assay,
that I'll go through
with you in your slides--
but you should understand--
it was found that a single
molecule called netrin, which
is a secreted ligand, a
secreted protein, that's
expressed in the floor plate--
which we'll talk
about in a moment--
is attractive for the
commissural neurons
and repulsive for the
trochlear neurons.
And it also turns out, as
we'll go through in a moment,
that this has to do
with different receptors
and different receptor dimers,
which bind the same ligand.
And so here there
is something called,
for the commissural
neurons, there
is something called a DCC--
DCC receptor dimer.
And for the trochlear
neurons, there
is a DCC UNC5 receptor pair.
And this will not
mean much to you,
but now you can write it down.
And then you can go
through your slides.
And you'll have a reference
point on right with you.
OK.
So here is the diagram.
The cell bodies of the
commissural neurons
are up in this region
of the spinal cord
called the roof plate.
It's the top of the spinal cord.
And on the bottom of the
spinal cord, near your belly,
there is a cone-shaped
group of cells
that forms this thing
called the floor plate.
The floor plate doesn't
actually make neurons.
It turns out to be a really
important source of signals.
It's an organizer, if you like.
And it not only organizes
these axons in the spinal cord,
it actually also
organizes your midline.
And it's one of the
reasons, if you're
missing the midline of
the body, things go wrong.
It's because the floor
plates are not there.
So the floor plate
is an organizer.
They are the commissural
neurons growing towards it.
And here are the trochlear
neurons growing away
from the floor plate.
This is what it looks like
if you do an immunostain.
The cell bodies are in red.
And here are the
commissural neurons
coming down in the spinal cord.
And this is a section
through the spinal cord, OK?
You've cut through--
cut through at the waist
and then turned the
section on its side.
So you're looking
into the spinal cord,
which would be coming out in
its length from the board--
from the screen.
All right.
Here's an explant assay to
figure out whether or not
that floor plate
has got something
to do with the direction that
those commissural neurons grow.
So on your handout,
the idea was to take
a piece of dorsal
spinal cord that
hadn't started to
send neurons out yet,
and to culture it together
in the laboratory,
in a plastic dish, with
some fluid nutrients,
and so on, and
ask what happened.
And if you did that,
that dorsal spinal cord
sent out neurons
towards the floor plate.
On the other hand, you can
see that that experiment was
specific, because if you put
the dorsal spinal cord together
with some roof plate,
nothing happened.
There was no outgrowth.
So there was something
special about this floor plate
that elicited that
commissural acts on outgrowth.
And the idea is that the
floor plate was attracting
the commissural axons.
This is what it
really looks like.
Here's a chunk of dorsal
spinal cord and floor plate.
And here are the growing axons.
And here's the
control experiment.
All right.
So what is the protein involved?
Well, the idea was that it was
something in the floor plate.
And it was really
hard to find this,
because there's not much of it.
Professor Tessier-Lavigne,
who is now
president of Rockefeller
University, but at the time
he was running a research
laboratory, and he
and many undergraduates,
and graduate students,
and post-docs, and so on,
went ahead and dissected many,
many little floor plates.
And they also found that
the brain of the chicken
contained the same
kind of activity.
So they dissected
out many thousands--
I believe it was 35,000--
chick brains and spinal cords.
And they did biochemistry
on this material.
And they used the explant
assay that I just showed you,
where instead of
the floor plate,
you'd have a little pellet
of material in which you
had soaked the
material that you've
purified by biochemistry,
from your smushed up,
dissected brains.
And from this-- it was really
successful-- from this,
they got a single protein.
Here's the RNA for the protein.
That's right expressed
in the floor plate.
That's what the white is.
That's the RNA.
This is an in situ
hybridisation.
And they called it netrin.
Netrin protein diffuses
away from the floor plate,
but it's still mostly
on this ventral side
of the spinal cord.
And you could show that
netrin was important,
because if you meet a
mouse that lacked netrin--
here's the mouse
that lacks netrin--
the commissural neurons
go all over the place.
They really don't
know where to go.
All right.
The netrin receptors,
as I drew on the board--
you can look on
your last handout--
are two-fold.
One of them are called
DCC, the tyrosine kinases.
They also activate GTPases
and do some other signal
transduction.
And when netrin binds
to a dimer of DCC,
you get F-actin that's made.
Microtubules grow.
And the growth cone extends.
On the other hand, when you get
this hetero dimer DCC and UNC5,
or a different homodimer, you
get cytoskeletal remodeling,
G-actin made, and the
growth cone collapses.
OK.
Close enough.
We'll stop there.